[Music]
let's do this river babes we're live and
you're here and I'm so excited to see
you
welcome to our sweet letter secrets
preview show for our winter finale of
Riverdale aka episode 308 chapter 43
outbreak
I'm your host Liana Galera and the last
time we went live you guys told me that
you wanted me to dress up as Miss Sheryl
bombshell so here I am hope you like it
now thank you so much for tuning in
today because in addition to going over
your hisses and kisses from 307 and
teasing you with my three clues about
the mid-season finale I'm also gonna be
responding to your live comments as well
so start sending me any questions common
theories that you have right now cuz
that's my favorite part of these lives
plus I just got back from a trip up to
Vancouver Canada where I spent an entire
day with almost all of my favorite
revered aliens and I've got so many
amazing behind-the-scenes secrets from
the cast to share now I'm gonna be
dishing many new interviews on sweet
water secrets so you River babes are
going to be full for months now starting
with today you're getting a Shoni update
from Vanessa Morgan and an introduction
to mama Jones from Cole Sprouse and Gina
Gershon herself but first let's take a
quick look back at your hisses kisses
comments and theories from episode 307
chapter 42 a man in black first up
Madison gruder's commented kisses to the
dialogue that we got to hear from Betty
she's taking over jugheads role and I'm
living for it yes when she called Ethel
a psycho [ __ ] I squealed and when I
caught up with Lilly on set she told me
that doing those voice-over recordings
was so much fun so I don't know about
you but I need more inner monologue
Betty next up whispering Brie's posted
what is it with people kissing Archie
and then injuring him first Joaquin and
now Lori gosh Archie's stupid shouldn't
he have learned not to be so trusting by
now okay this comment made me laugh now
who's going to smooch and smack Archie
next only time will tell and life of
brownie wrote kisses - Reggie supporting
Ronnie during the
the best moment of her life it seems
like he really cares about her and I
think we really need someone like that
right now
okay I do agree that Vee needs good
people in her life and Reggie has been
impressing me all off this season he
seems less douchey and more darling are
we liking veggie tell me in the comments
and speaking of Veronica sandy who spoke
her mind and wrote so Veronica elects
her dad but he almost killed her quote
Ed Gein boyfriend drove him away and
sells drugs yeah this is where that sure
Jam mean would play I didn't like that
scene where she was like maybe my dad
isn't so bad I just felt like ronnie was
smarter than that moment she knows
better moving on into theories territory
Anika ke dish okay I have a prediction
for who The Gargoyle King is I think
that it's actually Clifford posing as
his twin Claudius Clifford hyung
Claudius and faked his own death and now
he's back causing more trouble and akha
girl I love this theory I think it would
be super fun and a complete game-changer
I'm also gonna take it one step further
and I don't even think Claudius exists
there's that I just think it's Clifford
and furthering this cool thought Travis
Hunt added Jason was the original red
paladin he was the first sacrifice to
set it off wait you guys these two ideas
work so well together and I think it
would be amazing if all this Gigi
craziness linked all the way back to the
pilot we deserve an epic twist so do you
like this tell me in the comments and
lastly Rachel cherish commented hisses -
no Cheryl
tawny or Josie this episode next episode
better have shown E
don't you worry your pretty little
little self Rachel there is a great
Shoni scene in the winter finale and I
think I'll let Vanessa Morgan tease it
best take a look at what she told me
just a few days ago on set can you tease
about what's coming up in show knee in
the Riverdale winter fanatics I think
that fans will be quite pleased Cheryl's
gonna be taking care of me a little bit
you know maybe in her bed and there's
gonna be some Caesars at school remember
Adele's coming down with an epidemic and
it's really scary and Tony's gonna be
effect
I did love the super sweet quick kiss
that they got when they were so excited
when they're playing Griffin's and
gargoyles what is that written in the
script or did you add that in no that
was written in this room really what's
written in this we have had talked about
adding more just like because I know
Bucket does that a lot like we're
actually just comes yeah at it so we've
talked about maybe adding in a few of
those and if it stays days and if it
doesn't it doesn't because we want to
show you know fans more of that couple
east side of us an affectionate side
that you know maybe it's not written all
the time but you know an episode I think
it's episode 12 you know you really get
to see more of that side of show me
which is nice
are you happy show any fans I'm already
seeing so many of your comments and it
looks like you're happy and I know a lot
of you guys were tweeting me after we
got that quick bunker kiss between them
and we're wondering if that kiss was in
the script originally or not so I hope
you liked that behind the scenes
explanation that I got you from Vanessa
now moving on let's shift our focus to
this week's episode which is on the
episode 8 but they're calling it the
mid-season finale now keep in mind it is
not technically midseason at all there
will be 22 episodes again this year so
when I talk to Roberto this week he kind
of explained to me that they're breaking
up season 3 into kind of three different
parts or chapters but calling it a third
season finale that would be weird
but anyways let's take a look at the
promo for episode 308 chapter 43
outbreak Jughead jelly beans
there was a mass seizure at school it
will strap you to your beds an
electroshock the sin out of what's
coming next
it's practically biblical damn now as
far as trailers go that one was amazing
Cheryl I will follow you to any war you
want I loved seeing judgey smile when he
saw jellybean the math seizures are
disturbing and once again Hiram is being
his usual dramatic self but one of the
things I'm most excited about is to see
the missing puzzle pieces of the Jones
family and I just so happened to catch
up with Gina Gershon Cole Sprouse and KJ
Appa and here's what they had to tell me
about mama Jones and jellybean
me about when you first met Gina and
Trinity and finding that Jones family
bond I think it's challenging especially
for someone like Trinity as a young
actress to come into I show this in its
third season with a bunch of people who
kind of understand the Machine and sort
of acclimate right away Gina's a riot
she's of that as well so she she knows
exactly what she's doing she comes on
she she kicks ass oh you're not a
vegetarian now are ya you wound me
mother I had no idea really what to
expect
I think I'm used to having a little bit
more than a couple days to create a
character and there's a lot to do so I
just you know and everyone kept saying
wait what does this mean what's a
paladin what's who's this and it's so
funny because everyone was kind of
giving me their version and no you know
like who's a gargle
what's a gargoyle King never was like
well we think it's this and every answer
was different so I'm like okay then I I
got to catch up and I watched everything
which was really I kept thinking this is
the guilty pleasures watching everything
I'm like no no it's homework and I
really had a great time watching it so
now I'm all caught up and I know what
I'm doing that you two finally got
together huh no I knew there was
something going on between you that was
funny
it's probably the funniest line of that
episode I think that was fun I think I
think the fans are gonna get a kick out
of that line specifically I think
they're gonna I think they're really
gonna fall in love with Gladys
immediately
it's a really fun gang we're tough we're
tough don't mess with the Joneses yes I
already love Gena so much and I know
that you all love my three clues so
let's see if I can tantalize you even
more with my teasers about episode 308
all right number one what's my favorite
bedtime story the one where the princess
rescues herself from the dungeons yeah
number two yet another girl will be
charmed by Archie's good looks
hmm and number three we've seen the
gargoyle King but brace yourself throw
something even more ridiculous and
majestic PS you'll be getting a full
interview explaining number three and
our next Sweetwater Secrets after-show I
think you're gonna love it and now I
want to see what all of you River babes
have been coming to commenting to me
throughout this episode sorry I'm a
little excited keep sending me your
questions right now cuz we're going off
script and I'm reading what you're
saying to me okay so right away I'm
getting notes from my producers that
there are so much love for Shoni right
now so yes represent little Queens oh
wow there's so many okay Ana says I
would love jaar Chi I mean that comment
was amazing when I saw that Gladys made
that jar Chi comment I'm like yes they
would be a great pair I love them more
as a romantic old friendship but hey I
love that she was so supportive of that
Madison says I love veggie I think that
they're a cool pairing I am I need to be
convinced a little bit more but I think
that there could be something good there
I'm still of Archie fan and I still have
so much bar cheese scoop for you guys
and I'm gonna be dropping so stay tuned
for that just bringing it all down let's
see earlier comments are Cheryl says
Tony and I will have some big moments
tonight Oh Cheryl are you commenting
right now cold Xena says I love your
outfit Liam thank you I thought this one
was fun
shout out to hot topics with a cute
little cardigan Erna how do you think
Betty will be saved
go back to the clues my love go back to
the clues Phoebe will we have a bug head
reunion not in tonight's episode
John says I think the farm will save
Betty from the sisters of quite Mercy in
the episode they will try to convert her
into the farm I'm still waiting for us
to go to the farm I cannot wait to see
what's on the farm because I just think
that it's gonna be a great little
chapter of Riverdale and I cannot wait
to meet Edgar ever never Natalie says
Jughead and jellybean come home I think
hmm I don't know about that but I do
know that the actress Trinity who plays
jellybean is so sweet and when Cole was
talking about her during our interviews
he was so protective of her like an
older brother so I think it's gonna be
really cool to see their dynamic play
out together on screen Marisa says do
you know anything about a possible bug
head reunion of course I know things
about a possible bug head reunion Marisa
whether or not I can tell you about them
right now is TVD digital Alaska says
could you tease when we get a bug head
reunion and how Jughead will react to
finding out betty was in the sisters of
quiet mercy love Sweetwater secrets so
there is a moment where I talked to Cole
about the fact that a lot of you fans
have been wanting Jughead to get to know
that Betty was away in the sisters of
quite Mercy and he referred me back to
that line in last week's episode where
Archie was like oh should should we go
back to town and Jughead says to Archie
Betty chipped down a serial killer last
year I'm not worried
and it was just a really great thing for
to see that he's not worried about her
and we shouldn't be either oh my gosh so
many comments let's see
Aniki says aw Cole seems so nice to
Trinity he definitely is Zooey says I
think jelly bean is Betty's sister
instead of jugheads I don't think that
that would work because Gladys would
know if it was her daughter because she
would have carried her so I think it's
glad it's his daughter but they do look
alike Betty says I love or Maddie says I
love that Betty is going kind of like
young Alice and I love her hair down and
I really hope that that good old
ponytail phase is over so I love every
time that Lily gets to let her hair down
and she does too but the Betty ponytail
is so iconic and Roberto loves keeping
it
classic and so we're never gonna not see
Betty in a ponytail that's just never
not gonna happen
Alicia says LeAnn your gk impression
makes me laugh so much lol Twiggy
monster I can't help it every time I see
the guard girl King and as little Twiggy
yards I just go I'm sorry if you guys
think it's weird it amuses myself so I
keep doing it so I'm it's fine for me :
says will there be any more mevin scenes
please tell me I think you should watch
tonight it's a little bit of a blink and
you'll miss it moment but you'll be
happy about that mevin scene vide says I
swear to God if the girl who falls for
Archie is jelly bean or Gladys I will
kill myself I am NOT going to comment on
that one but please do not kill yourself
i I want you to keep watching Sweetwater
secrets and I want us to keep talking
about Riverdale together so many
comments Carly Betty will escape from
the sisters of quiet mercy by using the
dungeon and jellybean will have a crush
on Archie Oh Carly I think you're paying
very good attention to the show let's
see we have Alicia do you think Shoni
shippers will be happy I do think the
Shoni shippers will be happy I think
you'll be even happier when you see the
interview that I have from Vanessa
Morgan explaining what will make the
Shoni shipper so happy if that makes
sense
I think you know I think you're picking
up what I'm putting down Victoria says
will we see more phallus in upcoming
episodes because we didn't really get
anything about their relationship we
haven't gotten that much phallus this
year and it will be coming back into
play of course we're always gonna be
able to get more phallus but with the
introduction of Gladys I think that it's
going to put a little bit of a wrench in
things maybe stir up some some old
feelings as one would do when you see
your ex wife and mother of your children
I really do like the bond though that
Gladys and FP have so I think we're all
gonna start feeling a little torn
because you want families to be together
I don't know that's just me we're gonna
take a couple more comments you guys are
flooding this right now this is great
Kenzi loves a road trip commented which
Kenzi I love a road trip - so - Oni
why is jellybean blonde when Jughead has
blonde hair that I can't answer I think
that she's a cutie is a little blonde
girl so I might be a little biased but I
can't explain the genetics of that but I
like her
Mike says I want barchi by the end of
the season I can't take it anymore
barchi fans I do not have a barchi
update for you but I do have a Lilly and
KJ update coming for you so I asked them
about it when I was on set I will be
giving you their answers at some point
on Sweetwater secrets you just have to
keep tuning in and then you'll get to
see what they have to say I will say it
was positive things though Liam do we
get any clues about The Gargoyle Kings
identity tonight we do get a lot of
answers tonight whether or not those
answers will actually make sense to you
is TBD because I'm still really confused
Aisha says it's so cool how Cheryl's
brother is back because we couldn't see
a lot of him initially it shows brother
back that he died
do you guys know something I don't tell
me tell me Nikola in my opinion the
Serpent's along with Kevin will help
Betty escape also jellybean definitely
has a crush on Archie who doesn't have a
crush on Archie Aaron if the cargo is
king if the gargoyle King Chambers is in
the woods then I think that he is only
allowed when the head of sisters says
she controls him without being him I
love you xxx I love you too I'm not sure
what you were saying but I'm not sure
with a lot of things with Roberto these
days so I appreciate the stab it of that
we're gonna take just a couple more
comments and questions right now you
guys are flooding this Sprouse did s
says why has nobody noticed that Betty
was that sisters of quiet mercy but when
Sheryl was there they got to know
immediately it doesn't make any sense to
me
it does make sense when Sheryl was at
the sisters of quiet mercy Nana Rose
knew that she was took there and Nana
Rose called Vanessa her Nana Rose called
Tony and they went on that big rescue
mission no
has called any of the people you will
find out in tonight's episode what
Veronica like why she's not going after
Betty and what that excuses
so she Betty doesn't have bad friends
they just have other things going on
right now and also it's Betty
she's got this she's got this I'm just
two more let's see oh my gosh you guys
you guys are funny and you notice
everything and it's amazing
let's see do Archie and Jughead get
together that was by Anna our Jean
Jughead you not get together they're
just wonderful best friends but I mean
in some alternate reality I think I
would like to see that we'll see
Valley says is it true that Shoni is the
only couple that will have a scene
together in this episode and then she
says I love you so much Molly
I love you so much too it is not true
that Shauna is the only couple that will
have a scene together in tonight's
episode there are there's another couple
that has a quick scene together and
there is another former couple that
shares a scene together tonight so
there's that and oh and we'll end it on
on these last two Eleanor says well this
episode be like the last one with all
the gangs different stories no that is a
once-a-year special episode that roberto
and the cast actually really enjoyed
doing this one will have a lot more
moving pieces and a lot more of our cast
members which I am very excited about
because I get very sad when our series
regulars are not in the episodes I like
everyone to have equal time and there
will be an episode coming up later this
season that focuses on a lot of the
characters that we have not been seeing
a lot of this year so that makes me
happy
and I think well I think I hope that all
that made sense to you guys once again
but seeing all of your comments makes me
so happy you guys always flood my
mentions and you make me so excited to
to host these shows and to get to chat
with you guys you know you can always
chat with me on Twitter to send me all
of your comments and theories on there
and I'll tweet you back but tell me if
you want me to do sweet water secrets
live is more of a regular thing or just
something we do sporadically and yes
that was a clueless reference be sure to
check back with me as
soon as you've watched episode 308
chapter 43 outbreak for our aftershow
which is packed with more new interviews
from the cast especially an epic Shoni
explanation and an often Lily in Kol
interview also just a reminder for all
those Sabrina fans out there the special
holiday episode of chilling Adventures
of Sabrina comes out this weekend and
I'll be back with new episodes of my
other after-show witches Council and
I'll be breaking down all those
spellbinding twists but for now your
River babes know what to do give this
video a like hit subscribe and then
leave me your comments tell me your
Riverdale predictions for episode 308
your show any thoughts and what you
think of Gina Gershon as juggies mom I
love her I adore you River babe so much
and I'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you